Sí va a poder Cristina Fernández va a
poder apelar por supuesto todos los los
condenados van a poder apelar pero es un
proceso que que se demora claro hay que
esperar a la lectura de los fundamentos
del fallo que va a ser recién en 2023 y
todo proceso de apelación terminaría
eventualmente en una decisión que tiene
que tomar la Corte Suprema de Justicia
una Corte Suprema de Justicia con la que
hoy está enemistada Cristina Fernández
no está completa además tiene solo
cuatro miembros no hay acuerdos para
poder elegir el quinto miembro que falta
Cristina Fernández considera que debe
ser más grande bueno Y de todos modos
esa Corte Suprema aún como está
constituida ahora la decisión la tomaría
muchísimo más adelante Así que falta
falta todavía en lo que tiene que ver
con este fallo y su aplicación
[Música]